[Music]
on this Sunday night masks mitigate risk
but should they be mandatory again as
flu and RSV cases rise experts say it's
going to get worse for those of us who
are advocating for the Mandate it's
because the crisis is here now and
Ontario's Premier on the Mandate debate
Democrats hold control of the U.S Senate
the red wave that didn't pan out and
what it means for Donald Trump's 2024
bid inflation and your pension what's
going to happen next year what's going
to happen the year after why retirees
say payments are falling short
missing for a century but never
forgotten it's quite an incredible
moment solving the mystery surrounding a
young Canadian World War One vet
global national with para Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
being required to wear a mask is a harsh
reminder of what Canadians don't want to
experience again traveling back in time
to the beginning of the pandemic each
day adding that extra layer of
protection to keep you and your family
safe but with an acute triple demic
surging of covid-19 the flu and RSV and
overwhelmed hospitals and Healthcare
Staffing shortages the debate is back
it's political it's personal and it has
many divided tonight Sean O'Shea
explores if mask mandates are in our
future
with Canadian hospitals over stressed
with more sick patients than they can
handle the rise of respiratory illnesses
as the medical community and parents
worried across the country it's
absolutely alarming and it's urgent that
we see you know some sort of mitigation
because I can't imagine it getting worse
at this rate in Alberta just this week
more than twenty thousand sick calls to
schools in Edmonton prompted concern
and in Ontario the Chief Executive
Officer of Toronto's hospital for sick
children has publicly asked that Ontario
once again require masks in public
settings other doctors agree with that
idea for those of us who are advocating
for the Mandate it's because the crisis
is here now in an attempt to do whatever
you can to mitigate further spread
Pediatric Intensive Care units in
Ontario are operating Beyond capacity
many doctors say masks are needed the
goal of all of this and everybody agrees
regardless of whether it's a strong
suggestion or a mandate is to try and
get as many people as possible to wear
masks in indoor crowded settings masks
are unpopular with a lot of Canadians
right now not myself not so much no I've
become accustomed to not wearing a mask
as a blade and given a choice versus
being required to wear one this man's
opinion is a common one if it was a
recommendation at this point I think I
would probably not wear a mask that's me
personally but Ontario's Premier making
a political stop to announce he's
extending a gas tax break isn't ready to
make that the law again from day one all
the way through the pandemic I've always
listened to the chief medical officer of
Ontario Dr Karen Moore is expected to
announce a mask recommendation Monday
nothing more a premier Ford told
reporters Hospital CEOs haven't asked
him personally for a mandate seven
hospitals that I spoke to CEOs yes do
they they want uh masking no one told me
they wanted mandatory masking they
called for governments to do more in the
face of more respiratory illnesses is
growing we just need something right now
there's nothing at all we're just
navigating this on our own as parents
and as families the decision to require
masks or take other measures may be
based on medical recommendations But
ultimately their political decisions and
ones that provincial governments haven't
been prepared to make yet Farah
Shadow Shea reporting thank you Sean
and later in the newscast we're going to
look at how a strange Health Care system
is also impacting vital treatments for
cancer as the number of Canadians
diagnosed with the disease grows
prime minister Justin Trudeau has
announced nearly one million dollars to
help remove unexploded land mines and
cluster bombs from across Cambodia and
Vietnam he wrapped up meetings today at
the association of Southeast Asian
Nations Summit in Cambodia he's now
preparing for the G20 Summit in Bali
where Russia and China are expected to
be the key Focus this week globalist
Mackenzie gray is traveling with the
Prime Minister and has more Mackenzie
far The asean Summit in Cambodia has
come to an end but the prime minister's
next Asian challenge is just beginning
how to handle China at the upcoming G20
in Indonesia Trudeau will be seated
beside Chinese president Xi Jinping when
the summit starts Tuesday which could be
a little bit awkward after global news
reported ceases told the Prime Minister
that China allegedly interfered in the
2019 election by spending nearly a
quarter of a million dollars to fund 11
different candidates a topic Trudeau
wouldn't commit to bringing up I want to
come back to the question and drill down
on Xi Jinping are you going to raise
this specific issue with him as always I
will raise issues of Human Rights issues
of of
matters that preoccupy with Canadians
with any and all leaders that I engage
no clear response from Trudeau on how to
handle China but a different tone from
U.S President Joe Biden who's set to sit
down with she on Monday in a high
profile meeting I know him well he knows
me there's no we have very little
misunderstanding we just got to figure
out where the red lines are and what we
what are the most important things to
each of us finding red lines on issues
like Ukraine a subject that's set to
dominate the discussion in Bali the
Prime Minister backed up Canadian
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
saying he would meet with Russian
foreign minister Sergey lavrov at the
G20 I have a strong suspicion that the
Russian representative will not like
what he is going to be hearing from a
large number of of us at the G20 some of
those countries likely to join in
criticizing Russia are the newly elected
prime ministers in both the UK and Italy
and sources tell global news that Justin
Trudeau is expected to meet with both of
those leaders on the sidelines of the
G20 pharah
Mackenzie gray reporting thank you
in the U.S Democrats have retained the
Senate to Define polls and predictions
that the Republican Party would sweep in
a red wave for this year's midterm
elections last night votes for the
senate in Nevada came in giving Joe
Biden and his party the 50 seats needed
to maintain control and while votes for
the house are still coming in the
balance of power will be more evenly
spread than anyone predicted Jennifer
Johnson reports the battle for the U.S
Senate has been decided after Senator
Catherine Cortez masto squeaked out a
win in Nevada Democrats now hold 50
seats any tie vote will be broken by
vice president Kamala Harris to all
nevadans whether whether you voted for
me or not I will always fight for you
Cortez masto was considered the most
vulnerable of the democratic candidates
in a state where gas prices are some of
the highest in the nation voters were
concerned about inflation but also other
hot button issues like abortion rights
and gun control this election is a
victory a victory and a vindic education
for Democrats our agenda this was the
most successful midterm elections for
Democrats in 24 years most GOP
candidates endorsed by former president
Donald Trump lost many prominent
Republicans are pointing the finger
directly at Trump his influence was
always going to wane and I think the
disastrous outcome on this past Tuesday
much of it his responsibility good news
for President Biden As Trump is expected
to announce his candidacy for president
Tuesday although some Trump insiders are
encouraging him to wait and let the
fuhrer over the midterm losses die down
other former Trump supporters are
publicly hinting they will not back him
this time our party should be about the
future I think our next candidate will
be looking to the Future not to the Past
Democrats are still optimistic they can
hold on to the house although several
still undetermined races are leaning
Republican whatever the outcome were on
the path to taking our country to a
better place uh than was being dragged
down by the other side the final Senate
race in Georgia between former football
star Herschel Walker and Senator Rafael
Warnock will be decided in a runoff
election next month but the surprising
Democratic win so far are a clear sign
the so-called Republican Red Wave never
materialized
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
an explosion in central Istanbul on
Sunday afternoon has killed at least six
people and injured dozens of others the
bomb went off in a popular shopping and
tourist District sending hundreds of
people running in fear immediately after
the explosion the Turkish government
imposed a media ban on reporting and
asked citizens not to spread
misinformation online no group has
claimed responsibility for the attack
after those scenes of pure happiness and
War scarred her son following Russia's
Retreat from the Strategic Southern Port
City Ukrainian authorities have imposed
a curfew now
security is tight and travel in and out
of the city has been restricted
Ukrainian troops arrived in the center
of the city on Friday after Russia
abandoned the only Regional Capital its
forces captured since moscow's Invasion
began but the situation is still tense
there are rising fears Russian troops
digging in on the other side of the
nipro river will resume shelling in the
coming days
the push to protect Canadian pensions
coming up what the grueling rise in
living costs mean for this country's
retirees
Canada's historically High inflation is
making life difficult for many Canadians
who are already finding it tough to pay
the bills the rise in cost of living is
even outstripping payments to some
retired Canadians whose pension
increases are traditionally tied to
inflation Ross Lord reports
for retirees discovering pension
payments are falling short is a slap in
the face what we're saying is we
paid for this we have deferred a salary
basically and that was for retirement
purposes Clifford Kennedy is among 18
000 he runs with government retirees who
learned instead of the 5.56 percent
pension increase to cover the full cost
of inflation they'd only get five point
two four percent still a bigger bump
than many private sector employees
receive and more than retired public
servants in some other provinces but the
shortfall has created doubt for the
future and it's not because of the
amount it's the principle what's going
to happen next year
what's going to happen the year after
the New Brunswick Public Service pension
plan says its funding ratios which rely
on stock market Investments don't
currently allow for full indexing but it
says the remaining portion might be
delivered in future years there's better
news for federal retirees half a million
former government workers and xrcmp and
Military members will receive full
indexing pensioners will be receiving an
indexation increase effective January
1st 2023 of 6.3 percent the public
service Alliance says the average
pension benefit of almost 34 000 a year
will increase to almost 36 thousand two
thousand dollars higher those retirement
raises are the Envy of current federal
workers they are in a contract dispute
with the government because a wage
increase offer of two percent is nowhere
close to inflation the higher cost of
living casting a long Shadow for workers
both active and retired Ross Lord Global
News
cancer is a debilitating disease widely
known for its tragic consequences and
there's a new report that shows the
number of Canadians living with and
surviving cancer has now reached 1.5
million that's up from a million a
decade ago experts say medical
advancements have helped with earlier
diagnosis and treatments but there's a
concern that Canada's strained Health
Care system is setting back that
progress Jamie Maraca explains
harjikar was just 32 years old in 2019
when she was given a terrifying
diagnosis a rare form of blood cancer
that had progressed to stage four I
thought it might be some kind of
infection something but I never thought
that it would be cancer according to the
Canadian Cancer society's first
long-term prevalence report at the
beginning of 2018 an estimated one in 24
people in our country were living with
or were survivors of cancer and this is
due to both increasing incidents or the
number of people being diagnosed with
cancer which is increasing due to our
aging and growing population but also
improvements in survival with more
people
expected to survive their cancer
diagnosis the report found about 60
percent of the patients were still alive
after 5 to 25 years doctors credit early
diagnosis new treatments and research
but resources aren't keeping Pace with
advancements and access to care is
increasingly difficult stretch thin in
part because of kova 19. currently we
are working through if you like a queue
of people
who are just now having cancers
diagnosed or just now initiating their
treatment
because their diagnosis was delayed
without invest
supporting policy Advocates warn the
backlog will worsen we need support
from our federal Partners this week
Health ministers from across the country
requested a boost in health funding from
Ottawa cash the federal government says
could come but with conditions now 35
Carr is one of thousands of patients
whose treatment was impacted by the
pandemic things were delayed you know
treatment was delayed eventually she
received a stem cell transplant and
while a recent scan showed no sign of
the disease her need for care continues
things have changed a lot after cancer
right I'm not the same person this is my
new normal and one she hopes our Health
Care system can keep up with Jamie
moroccer Global News
[Music]
Margaret Brooks lasting Legacy ahead the
inspiring woman and namesake behind a
ship protecting Canada's North
Canada's presence in the Arctic is
heating up as the Region's warming
climate changes the course for future
Maritime patrols earlier this year hmcs
Margaret Brooks set sail to Canada's far
north but the ship made history long
before that our Jeff sempel spent time
on board the new Icebreaker and as he
reports Margaret Brooks story inspired a
generation of Navy personnel to follow
in her footsteps
even before she set sail for the first
time this year this Arctic Patrol vessel
had already made history
the first Royal Canadian Navy ship to
ever be named after a woman hmcs
Margaret Brook I think that the ship in
itself is a really important symbol for
Canadians Margaret Brook was a nursing
sister with the Royal Canadian Navy
during the second world war and The
Story Goes that she was treating an
Irish patient in hospital and as a thank
you he gifted her a four-leaf clover for
good luck
in October 1942 Brooke and her friend
Agnes Wilkie were aboard a ferry off the
coast of Newfoundland when it was struck
by a torpedo from a German submarine
there is no Lifeboat for her or Agnes
and the ship sunk very quickly within
about five minutes I understand and so
when the ship sunk she went down with it
Brooke's nieces say their aunt tried
desperately to save her friend but
couldn't incredibly Brooke clung to an
overturned Lifeboat and was eventually
rescued in her pocket she discovered
she'd been carrying that four-leaf
clover she said she felt the reason she
survived was the four leaf clovers in
her pocket Brooke became the first
Canadian nursing sister to be made a
member of the order of the British
Empire the ardath Saskatchewan native
spent 20 more years with the Navy rising
to the rank of sub Lieutenant after
retirement she earned a PhD becoming a
scientist and University Professor then
on her 100th birthday in 2015 Brooke
heard the news the Navy was naming a new
Icebreaker in her honor
Rook died the following year her family
attended the ship's official
commissioning in her honor
she always felt that women had to work
extra hard in order to get equivalent
recognition and the fact that they were
recognizing her this way it was a
confirmation in her mind that you know
her contribution had been recognized she
went on and did some great things in the
Navy and within her career after the
Navy
she was a Trailblazer for for women
Transit belt Street Nicole robichow is
the ship's commanding officer one of
only a few female commanders in the Navy
and many of the senior officers are also
women it actually is incredibly
important especially to you know young
women who maybe haven't pictured
themselves being in the military before
and for the first time these Sailors are
letting their hair down during our visit
this fall the Navy updated its dress
code allowing Sailors to grow and color
their hair even their nails it seems
like a small thing to be able to paint
your nails and dye your hair different
colors but it actually has I think it's
a really significant indicator of where
we're moving to in the future and the
kind of spirit of this is that we're
being more inclusive as an idiot
Commander robichow likes to think
Margaret Brook would be proud and that
she's watching over them hanging outside
her quarters is a gift from Margaret
Brooks family her old locket containing
that same four-leaf clover we always
thought it was good luck charm yeah
so that was important so to keep them
safe a source of comfort and inspiration
from a woman who spent a lifetime
charting a new course
Jeff Semple Global News aboard hmcs
Margaret Brook
[Music]
leaving no one behind next a lost
Canadian Soldier is found more than a
century later
[Music]
as we honor Canada's war heroes this
month we also remember that many fallen
soldiers who were never buried in marked
Graves there are more than 27 000
Canadian service members who are still
considered missing from the first and
second world wars in the Korean
conflicts but as skeletal remains are
discovered there's a team of forensic
anthropologists who are piecing together
who they were and where they came from
Heather York's West has a story of one
young man from Calgary who went missing
more than a century ago
there were just a handful of Clues to
start with including damaged artifacts
discovered alongside human remains in
France during the summer of 2017. the
site of a bloody battle this was a young
soldier who had died during the first
world war the big mystery who could he
be
Dr Sarah lockyer is the forensic
anthropologist in charge of finding out
the process really begins when we're
told that a discovery has happened
Canada suffered heavy losses here in the
Battle of Hill 70. ten thousand soldiers
dead over just 10 days with more than
1300 still unaccounted for that's where
Dr lock here began with a list of
potential names for this Unknown man
we're able to start narrowing down the
list of potential candidates that's
linked to the biological data especially
things like age and height Dr lockyer
began to suspect these remains belonged
to a man who had enlisted in Calgary a
DNA test confirmed his name there are no
known photos of private Harry Atherton
born in England he lived for a short
time in McBride BC he was wounded first
in 1916 before returning to battle he
died at age 24. it's quite an incredible
moment to be able to say that we have
been able to return this person's name
and their face to them private Atherton
was a member of the 10th Battalion
Canadian expeditionary Force which was
actually perpetuated by two regiments
serving in the Canadian Army today it
means that even more than a century
later private Harry Atherton is
considered one of the Calgary
Highlander's own and so it will be
members of this regiment who will travel
to France next year to be present when
this Soldier is finally given a proper
burial I think it's going to be a deeply
emotional and profound Journey for those
soldiers that do get to go over to
France I hope he's reassured that
members of his regiment are coming
together to take care of him today
missing for 100 years but never
forgotten at last finally able to lay at
rest Heather urich's West Global News
Calgary
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser and I want
to thank you for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
this great horned owl in Long Island
Newfoundland and Labrador Donna will be
back with you tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and each other
good night
[Music]